I feel so cool welcome to 5 lambda
uh-huh what are you doing we don't hit
joints in here your parties must suck no
we don't throw parties here in the
United States sororities are not allowed
to throw parties on their own houses
only Brides can these are the sexist
restrictive system norma's our sorority
they can party the way that we want to
what's the name of our sorority Kappa
Kappa nu we are the first awardee back
and welcome to our sorority Kappa nu
we're never gonna sell our house with a
sorority living next door what are we
gonna do baby it's not that bad girls
are usually quiet don't really take hard
drugs and they're much smarter
oh no I killed a girl we need somebody
who can relate to stupid young people
hey neighbors let's shut this [ __ ] down
my theme song mark my let the black seen
these guys is everyone you look like a
psychopath hey clown man people love
clowns stop doing that middle America
pattern antal our sorority I got an idea
we go with the airbag trip that's not
gonna work if it worked with guys why
won't it work for girls guys are idiot
it's a little hard to call the cops
without a phone give us that back yeah
Oh what it's called cork dumbass those
girls are out of control they're using
their sexuality as a weapon you don't
understand that there's no I in
sororities there's two actually there's
actually there's just one no that's a
why no in the middle that's a no SOR oh
I tet1 sorority that's how you spell it
you think that it e is silent